[Musique]
madame Léré vous avez fait l'objet le 3
février 2023 d'une ordonnance de mise en
accusation du chef de meurtre par
conjoint pour avoir volontairement donné
la mort à Monsieur Jimmy
Gautier une femme est jugée pour le
meurtre de son mari
violent un procès comme il y en a tant
d'autres dans les
tribunaux mais ici rien n'est vrai
l'accusé dans le box n'a commis aucun
crime d'ailleurs son avocate n'en est
pas une et la présidente n'avait
jusque-là jamais porté la robe rouge
tous sont de simples citoyens qu'il y a
quelques semaines encore ne connaissaiit
rien de la justice mais sont animés
d'une même envie la découvrir de
[Musique]
l'intérieur un mois avant l'audience
Julie arrive au tribunal pour une
première réunion elle a répondu à un
appel à candidature lancé par le
tribunal judiciaire d'Orléan et fait
partie des 15 citoyens sélectionnés très
accompagnés par des avocats et des
magistrats professionnels ils vont
devoir peu à peu se glisser dans la peau
des acteurs d'une cour
d'assise tous ces rôles qui vont
s'imbriquer que chacun vous allez
vraiment intégrer et qui va nous
permettre de jouer vraiment ce procès
fictif comme si vous étiez des acteurs
comme si vous étiez vraiment le
président d'audience l'avocat on va vous
enrober on va vous mettre vos robes on
va vous mettre vous allez tout avoir
comme dans un procès normal la plupart
d'entre eux n'a jamais assisté à un
procès ils vont pourtant être précipités
dans la fausse des assises là où sont
jugés les crimes les plus
graves un c'est le lieu de toutes les
émotions et souvent les plus
fortes mais c'est le lieu où il ne faut
pas se laisser guidé par ses
émotions déjà c'est compliqué vient le
moment de distribuer les rôles
tous les trois vous voulez toujours être
président ou est-ce que vous trois il y
a finalement un rôle vous vous êtes dit
maintenant qu'on m présenter ça me j'ai
envie de faire un autre rôle avocat
général c'est pris alors avocat général
il y a aussi du succès pour avocat
général évidemment personne ne rêve
d'être l'accusé pourtant c'est un beau
rôle l'accusé c'est moi qui me suis
proposé je joue le le le rôle de
l'accusé de cette femme victime de
violence
euh qui tue son mari ça me ramène à moi
ce que j'ai pu vivre avant pendant mes
20 et quelques années de mariage où j'ai
été victime de violence conjugale alors
psychologique je me dis ce rôle ça ça
peut être une thérapie pour moi pour me
permettre
d'avancer déjà ben je vous remercie tous
d'être d'être venu
aujourd'hui vous avez normalement tous
pris connaissance déjà du du scénario en
sachant qu'on va vous proposer peut-être
nous des petits ajustements de semaines
avant le grand jour les citoyens acteurs
se retrouvent pour travailler leur rôle
ils doivent aussi apprendre comment se
déroule un procès et surtout quelle est
la mission de chaque protagoniste j'ai
compris he le rôle de l'Avocat c'est
d'essayer d'expliquer à la cour la vie
un peu de
l'accusé le l'enfance l'adolescence et
puis le quotidien là en l'occurrence
avec son mari ce qu'il l'a poussé à à
commettre ce geste dans la vie yann est
expert comptable il jouera le rôle de
l'Avocat général c'est le procureur des
assises celui qui représente les
intérêts de la société à la fin des
débats il devra prendre un réquisitoire
c'est-à-dire suggérer au jury la peine
qu'il estime juste pour les 8 années
de rclusion criminelle le prononcer euh
le 8 années c'est vous qui l'avez validé
c'est très sincèrement moi Jeuris je
requererai plus oui après moi moi pour
moi un meurtre avec des réquises en
dessous à un chiffre j'ai du mal à y
croire ce qui ne préjuge pas de ce que
va dire la cour après hein donc là j'ai
appris deux choses la première c'est que
il recurit en leur âme et conscience et
non pas de façon euh collégiale ou autre
donc c'est cha avocat général qui décide
de sa propre réquisition et la deième
chose c'est que on est que sur de
l'humain pour de l'humain et par de
l'humain et c'est très compliqué de
déterminer la juste peine pour l'avocat
général quoi requérir quoi plaider mais
aussi quelle attitude quel ton adopter
en peu de temps ils vont devoir réussir
à imiter l'éloquence qu'un homme de loi
mais des années à acquérir moi j'ai
aussi tendance si vous voulez si je sens
que euh les gens écoutent mois je
m'arrête de parler ouais moi je fais ça
aussi je m'arrête de parler vous
imaginez pas lorsque les gens vous
entendent parler et qu'ils ont l'air un
peu perdu qu' vous entendent plus
aussitôt il raccrochent et là vous
réattaquez c'est un métier qu'il enfin
des métiers qu'ils ne connaissent pas
notamment celui d'avocat général déjà le
terme avocat général parfois peut peut
prêter à confusion et la personne qui
jouera le rôle de l'Avocat général on a
bien senti que finalement il sait pas
comment se positionner il sait pas ou
même la personne qui va être avocate
elle sait pas comment elle doit parler
elle sait pas elle sait pas comment elle
va s'adresser donc voilà on donne on
donne quelques indications mais ce n'est
que très très
[Musique]
parcellire 4 octobre jour de la nuit du
droit au tribunal c'est jours de stress
c'est lourd ah oui hein ça ti j un
peuement dernière répétition en tenue
avant de se confronter au
public AA tout le poids de la justice
sur mes
épaules bonjour bonjour Amandine est
étudiante en droit plus tard elle espère
devenir magistrate je mets la robe c'est
vraiment un honneur de l'ppter j'ai
l'impression d'être la vraie présidente
de la cour d'assise on se dit ça y est
c'est maintenant c'est toi la présidente
et c'est toi qui qui va juger c'est toi
qui auras le dernier mot et c'est vrai
que c'est très impressionnant Mesdames
et Messieurs les jurés elle découvre la
solennité d'une audience chacun a une
place bien précise et doit intervenir
quand c'est son tour une sorte de
cérémonial qui est le même à chaque
procès 3 l'avocat général lui il peut
partir là mais il reste pas c'est
quelque chose d'avoir le texte dans les
mains et c'est autre chose après d'être
vraiment positionné dans le rôle de
l'Avocat positionné dans le rôle de
l'expert dans le rôle du président il
faut avoir aussi la vision de la salle
pouvoir poser sa voix correctement et
regarder les bonnes personnes et
vraiment se mettre dans la peau du
personnage une bonne fois pour
[Musique]
toutes 200 personnes se sont inscrite
pour cette nuit du
droit des citoyens eux aussi curieux
d'en découvrir davantage sur la
justice avant d'assister à l'audience on
leur projette le film arrêtez-moi sorti
en 2013 c'est de lui que s'inspire ce
procès
fictif quoi tu veux sauter tu veux
sauter hein
sa je poussé dans les
en coulisse latention monte la
présidente sera la première à
entrer c'est
maintenant au moment d'appuyer sur la
sonnette j'ai le trac je suis stressée
je commence à rougir et je rentre on a
vraiment l'impression d'être un
magistrat professionnel veuillez vous
asseoir l'heure est venue de juger
Sophie leré cette femme victime de
violence conjugale qui a poussé son mari
du
balcon le fait de rentrer alors qu'ils
appellent le bocal l'aquarium là on se
dit je suis je je je suis assise à la
place d'un meurtrier en fait ça fait
peur parce que finalement j'ai pas envie
d'être
là c'est c'est trop pesant en fait
madame Sophie Léré je vais procéder au
tirage au sort des si juré chargé de
vous juger comme dans un vrai procès les
jurés sont tirés au sort ici parmi des
volontaires dans le public juré numéro
6 les débats sont ouverts à la barre
défil suite les enquêteurs les experts
et les témoins c'est vrai qu'il
s'engueul des fois très fort l'accusé
elle est interrogé sur les faits mais
aussi sur les violences qu'elle a subi
je me suis pas vu en tant que victime
conjugale c'était devenu ma routine
c'était ma vie il fallait que je le
fasse avec
pour moi et pour
Cédric j'ai bien sûr songé à le quitter
mais j'avais peur des conséquences et
là bien de d'émotion parce que c'est la
partie qui qui me ressemble le plus par
rapport à ce que j'ai vécu par rapport
aux angoisses que que j'ai pu avoir à un
moment donné j'ai l'impression de
raconter mon histoire sur certains
points j'ai l'impression de raconter mon
histoire donc donc oui on se est dans la
peau du du du personnage en fait c'est
au tour de Yann l'avocat général
d'annoncer la peine qu'il requiert en se
faisant justice selon son bon vouloir en
allant jusqu'à donner la mort elle s'est
érigée en juge en bourreau
or les juges c'est
vous je vous demande de condamner madame
Sophie Léré
à 12 années de réclusion criminelle pour
meurtre aggravé sur
conjoint au moment où on déclame et que
tout le monde va écouter on a cette
solénité et c'est vraiment un
moment imperceptible où on a le pouvoir
deeux mais la responsabilité d'eux aussi
faut regarder quand même cette femme
dans le box derrière cette vide dans les
yeux et lui disant je requi 12 années
c'est quand même quelque chose c'est une
expérience sa vivre je vous demande
mesdames et messieurs la plus grande
clémence comme le veut la procédure
après la plédoirie de son avocate le
dernier mot revient à l'accusé je dirais
juste madame la Présidente que que je
suis heureuse mon fils a enfin dit la
vérité merci Cédric merci beaucoup
l'audience est
suspendue la cour se retire pour
délibérer à huclos pour cette étape la
plus délicate un vrai président de cour
d'assise va les assister un vote un juré
un magistrat professionnel ça a la même
valeur c'estàdire que au moment où on
vote il y a pas un juge plus important
qu'un autre chacun fait en fonction son
intime
conviction le vote qu'il entend
faire dans la réalité les délibérations
prennent plusieurs heures pendant ce
temps le public a exceptionnellement été
invité lui aussi
et voici son ver la personnalité de la
victime madame Sophie l est-elle
coupable d'avoir à dkerer le 7 février
2011 volontairement donner la mort à
Jimmy Gautier à 61 % vous avez répondu
non c'est-à-dire que Madame Léré est
déclaré non coupable le public vient
d'acquitter Sophie Léré la peine
annoncée par la Cour elle est forcément
moins
clémente la cour et jury après avoir
délibéré conformément à la loi vous
condamne à la peine de 8 ans de
réclusion criminelle l'audience
élevée c'est pas surprenant qu'il y ait
une telle différence entre une
déclaration de non culpabilité dans la
salle et à l'inverse une déclaration de
culpabilité dans le cadre d'un jury qui
a été effectivement constitué qui a
appris sa décision en étant accompagné
par des magistrats professionnels qui
expliquent équilibre qu'on doit trouver
entre l'émotion d'un débat mais aussi
l'aspect juridique de ce débat et ce qui
a manqué à la salle c'est cette
accompagnement
là les acteurs de ce procès ne sont pas
devenus des hommes et des femmes de loi
en un mois mais ils en savent désormais
bien plus sur le système judiciaire que
beaucoup de citoyens on a toujours un
regard assez négatif en fait sur la
justice en France le fait de venir à ce
genre de de d'événement ça permet de
laavir autrement et de se dire que il y
a aucune place qui est facile je suis
venu avec une vision qu'on a dans les
films et là évidemment on a quel vision
beaucoup plus réaliste des choses mais
oui c'est une vraie chance de participer
à cette aventure
oui 149 juridictions de France ont
ouvert leurs pores pour cette nuit du
droit avec l'objectif de rendre la
justice plus accessible moins
austère moins
[Musique]
opaque
I